all right sally well love is in the air
valentine's day is tomorrow february
22nd 2022 which is also coming up also
expected to be a big day for weddings
madison kimbrough is live at harry reid
international airport with details on
the county's pop-up marriage license
bureau there so madison what are you
guys seeing out there
you know sasha it's always busy here at
the airport especially with valentine's
day weekend and the upcoming palindrome
date the county is expecting a great
turnout this month the pop-up marriage
license bureau is open from 8 a.m to 4
p.m daily from february 10 until the
22nd in the airport's terminal one
baggage claim area near corosal five
this is the fourth year the clerk's
office has opened this temporary bureau
at the airport and with the las vegas
being the wedding capital of the world
couples love the convenience being able
to get their marriage license right when
they land
they can get off the plane grab their
bags and then pick up their marriage
license before they even get your taxi
so that's been very popular um both for
the couples and for the airport and for
our uh bureau because it just makes it
more fun and easy for couples so they
can spend more time doing the fun things
that vegas has to offer
couples are encouraged to register
online at mlic.vegas
to decrease their wait time either at
the airport or at the marriage license
bureau main office that's downtown now
as for february 22nd 2022 goya says many
chapels are already booked up so wedding
chamber dot vegas will provide a list of
places still available for couples to
check out reporting inside of the
airport madison kimbrough live local now